LISA LEE: Good
afternoon, everyone.
And welcome to another exciting
event here at Tech Corners.
And I want to give a
huge shout-out to Regina.
Where is she?
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Regina,
for coordinating all
your hard work that
goes into this.
I mean it took an hour.
But it takes her weeks, I'm
sure, to put this all together.
I'm Lisa Lee.
And I'm really incredibly
excited to introduce
Luboc Azria, the chief creative
officer at BCBG Max Azria
Group, a global fashion house,
with one of the hottest labels
and brands in the
fashion industry today,
that styles everyday
modern women like you
and I, in the contemporary
price point range,
to supermodels and
Hollywood celebrities.
She joined the company
as a designer in 1991
and was named creative
director in 1996.
Under her influence-- and
I've been told that she's also
known as the muse
of the company--
it evolved from an emerging
line to one of America's leading
design houses, including being
the first American design house
to absorb the esteemed French
fashion house, Herve Leger.
She's joining us
here today at Google
to share an exclusive screening
of the 2015 Spring Runway Show
and to provide it with
some personal commentary.
LUBOC AZRIA: Absolutely.
LISA LEE: And if
that isn't enough,
I'm really impressed
that she's also
a mother of six,
three [INAUDIBLE].
[CHEERS]
So you'll have to tell
us your secret and how
you balance all that.
And obviously, you
look so beautiful.
So welcome to Google.
LUBOC AZRIA: Thank you.
Hi everyone.
How's everybody doing today?
AUDIENCE: Good.
LUBOC AZRIA: Good.
Well, I'm very happy to be here.
So it's very exciting.
And I think we
should start, right?
LISA LEE: Yes.
So really just to start
off so that everyone
gets to know you a
little bit better,
if you can tell us a
little bit about yourself,
and some of your
passions, and how
that translates into your
personal style, and the work
that you do?
LUBOC AZRIA: So I'm
originally from Ukraine, Kiev.
How many of you actually
were not born here?
OK.
So you'll love this story.
So briefly, I was born in Kiev.
And I think that your
cultural background sometimes
defines you.
I think when I was
growing up, I was
meant to be a prima ballerina.
So from the age of
4 and 1/2 to 5--
actually, I was about 5
years old, where they come
and they test you, how limber
you are and everything else.
Your life is determined.
And so I trained in-- there's
like little satellite groups
of Kirov ballet.
So that's how my
initial training was.
But my true passion
was always art.
And I loved drawing
and painting.
And I took art classes.
Anyway, in the 1980s, Brezhnev
signed an agreement with Israel
to let the Jews out.
I'm Jewish.
And there was a huge
prosecution against Jews.
We couldn't attend universities.
We couldn't actually
get higher jobs.
We couldn't do a lot of things.
So my parents were
lucky enough to leave.
And so we immigrated
to the United States.
And the place that we end
up in is San Antonio, Texas.
[LAUGHTER]
Of all the places, it
was San Antonio, Texas.
And so I really started
growing up there.
And I have to say that I never
thought of fashion as fashion,
like I didn't know the
fashion industry existed.
In the former
Soviet Union, it was
like everybody was wearing the
same thing over and over again.
So I didn't really realize
that there was a fashion world.
All I wanted to do was to
be an art history professor.
So I studied art.
I was really
passionate about it.
And obviously, I danced
as well, on the side.
And so in 1986, there was
an oil crisis in Texas.
And a lot of people
lost their jobs.
And so we moved
from San Antonio,
Texas-- and I know
it's a lot of story.
But there's a good point to it.
So we moved from San Antonio,
Texas to Los Angeles.
And I remember being in LA.
And I am 18 years old.
And I don't know
what my future is.
All I know is that
I want to be in art.
I want to be in something
that really has--
the possibilities are endless.
And I can create something
that can make a difference.
So anyway, I am in Los Angeles.
And it's two weeks
after I arrived there.
And I decided to go shopping.
And I went on
Wilshire Boulevard.
So I'm just walking on Wilshire.
I don't know if you
guys, any of you know LA?
But it's like a-- anyway,
there's large department stores
there.
So I was walking by one
of the department stores.
And there was the most
beautiful dress in the window.
I mean the dress
was so stunning.
And I decided that I'm
just going to go in.
I've never been to
this department store.
But I'm going to go
in and try it on.
As I walk in, I ask for the
dress that in the window.
And the sales person there said,
well, it's on the second floor.
We having a new trunk show.
They gave me the dress.
And so I went into the
dressing room, put it on.
It was stunning.
It was the most beautiful
thing I've ever had on.
I started twirling in the dress.
I mean just having a good time,
until I saw the price tag.
And the price-- now,
remember, this is in 1986.
So the price tag was $3,000.
And I remember my
car was $1,500.
[LAUGHTER]
So that it was
not going to work.
And at that moment,
as I was looking
at myself in the mirror, at
that moment that pain hit me.
The pain was that
I'm not good enough.
What am I doing here?
People like me don't
wear clothes like that.
Really, like all
the negative things
just started flowing through me.
And I started crying, but
sort of tearing up more.
And then I pulled
myself together.
I looked in the mirror
and I said, if I ever,
ever become a
designer, I will never
make clothes that
are that expensive.
I will never make a
woman feel this pain.
Nobody deserves
to feel this pain.
And I made that promise.
I took off my dress.
Now, again, I didn't know it
that I wanted to be a designer.
I had no idea.
Took off the dress,
put it on the hanger,
zipped it up, thanked the
sales people, and left.
Next day, believe it
or not-- not next day,
but like two days after,
a fashion school came in.
And I filled out,
saying I liked fashion.
I like this.
My whole life from that moment
on-- it's like in that movie
when you make a promise,
everything, like, starts
opening for you, everything
in my life from that point on.
I went to fashion school-- well,
I filled out a application.
The next thing I knew, I
was in the fashion school.
The next thing I
knew, I had a job.
It was just everything
was just incredibly--
it's like my destiny was
created at that moment.
And I don't know if any of
you had that experience.
But it's just sort of, you do
thing and you make a promise.
And then everything
in your life changes.
And so to me,
fashion represents--
it's not just about clothes.
But it's about
making a difference.
Do you know I'm saying?
I believe that if you make a
woman feel and look beautiful,
she can make this
world a better place.
LISA LEE: So it looks like
it all crystallized for you.
LUBOC AZRIA: Yeah.
Yeah.
LISA LEE: And so
from that point on,
how does that experience--
how does that translate
to your designs today, and
the labels, and what you do?
LUBOC AZRIA: Well, it
translates in every way.
I mean until this day, I
fit every single piece.
I also kind of realized
that-- for example, I
don't know if you know
anything about making clothes.
But you can take a dress that
you're wearing, for example.
You can take a dress
like this and you
can have it 10 times
more expensive,
if you don't think about the
marker, and the fabrication,
and how it moves.
So we really engineer
everything to give you
the best price that we can.
Because I believe that a
woman has to feel good.
Most designers
don't appreciate, I
think, the consumer and
their spending power.
Or their knowledge, I
think I would want to say.
Like, women are so much smarter.
You don't have to be in fashion
business to understand fashion.
You don't have to be.
You know what you like.
And that's the most
important thing.
Fashion is about
connecting with something.
So what I do is I create
clothes that I want to wear.
I'm a woman.
It's so interesting because
in design, we always
think that we're somebody else.
But we're not.
We're women.
The majority of my
team is also females.
And then we love what we do.
We get excited
about the product.
We can't wait to
wear it ourselves.
We can't wait to create
a product that we
respect and want to wear.
And I think that's
the difference.
We don't have to
do a lot of things.
Like I will not create clothes
just to create clothes.
I really want somebody
wearing it and feeling
beautiful and elegant.
And I believe that
you live one life.
How do you want
to live your life?
Do you want to
hide behind clothes
or do you want to
celebrate yourself?
And if somebody would
take a picture of you
every single day, would
you be proud of that?
You know, one life.
And so to me, that's
very important.
LISA LEE: That's really,
really inspirational.
And I think it's something
for people to keep in mind.
But many of us
here, I'm sure, are
busy working women, as well
as some of us have kids.
And so how do you
balance that in terms
of getting up every day and
to think about yourself first,
as opposed to your family and
all the other responsibilities?
LUBOC AZRIA: Well, like I said,
think about yourself first.
I mean there's a safety
message on the plane.
It says when the
oxygen mask comes down,
put it on yourself first,
and then on your children.
And I think a lot of
women don't do that.
We tend to take care
of everybody else.
And then we feel like
something's wrong with us.
And I think truly taking care
of yourself is so important.
And I'm not talking
about that idea.
I'm talking about exercising,
eating right, doing the things
that you love.
If you love, for example, I
don't know, roller blading,
go rollerblade.
If you love, making jewelry--
if you love anything,
do you know what I'm saying,
make sure you're doing it.
Because that is what's
going to satisfy who you are
and create-- in life,
you don't find yourself.
You create yourself.
So create the type of
person that you want to be.
Most people go around
the world and go, oh,
this person is so chic.
She was born that way.
She wasn't born that way.
She created herself.
Do you now what I'm saying?
She watched.
She learned.
And she wanted to
be that person.
So you become that.
And I think in terms of
balance and being a mom,
I think being a mom
is one of the greatest
gifts in the world.
I mean those kids are
our greatest teachers.
And yes, they're tough.
But that's because they're
trying to find who they are.
And we just have
to let them grow.
And I think being friends with
your children is so important.
I think we're always trying
to tell them what to do.
And I think, don't.
I think they'll do
the right thing.
I notice the less I
tell them what to do,
the more strict they
are on themselves.
And I have five
daughters so it's
kind of like-- it's
a party at the house.
LISA LEE: So I have to
ask, because my daughter,
they always decide
what they want to wear.
And it doesn't always match.
LUBOC AZRIA: Oh.
LISA LEE: And you're
like, do you really
want to put those
two things together?
So do you let them
experiment and let them?
LUBOC AZRIA: Yes.
Actually, I think that's how you
create fashion, by being wrong.
I don't think fashion should--
I mean we don't match here.
It's a piece that she likes.
She probably likes this
great pair of shoes
and she just wants-- it's about
certain things that they love.
And let them do it.
I mean I remember my kids,
I couldn't get them out
of Halloween costumes
for, like, a year.
And I said, hey, if you want
to be a superwoman, go ahead,
every single day, or tutus.
I mean that was, like, number
one search word, right?
Or like a item, tutu skirts.
[LAUGHTER]
Mine is in the car, with the
bathing suit and flip-flops.
No.
But it is.
Just let her be.
I mean obviously she
has a reason for it.
How beautiful is that?
LISA LEE: Right.
And so you often hear
people define their style.
They saying I'm casual or
I like the bohemian look.
Do you believe in that?
Or do you feel like it's-- like
you talked about experimenting.
And so what is behind
that definition
and do you encourage women
to sort of throw that
out the window and
say just wear what
you feel is most comfortable
and defines you for the day?
LUBOC AZRIA: Uh-uh.
I think it depends
on your lifestyle.
I think that most
of us-- I mean,
it depends if you
want to blend in.
Like, I think that women
should experiment with stuff.
I think that's playing.
Do you remember when we used
to play with clothes, dress-up,
and all this?
What happened to us?
We stopped playing.
We stopped experimenting.
We stopped living.
If you're taking fashion too
serious, you're doing it wrong.
You're supposed to go in and try
every single thing in the store
and have fun.
Because women do not
dress based on trends.
They dress based on
their body shape, period.
You know what's going to
look good on you, right away.
You don't need a
salesperson to tell you.
So you know if you look
good in strapless dresses,
you wear strapless dresses.
If you look good in v-neck,
you look good in v-neck.
That's because you know it.
You put it on and it's right.
And that's the difference.
Comfort, obviously, is
extremely important.
But you can be
elegantly comfortable.
LISA LEE: So when you are
feeling a little down or maybe
feeling you don't quite
have the confidence,
what's your go-to outfit that
you'd sort of recommend people
think about.
LUBOC AZRIA: A really
big muumuu, sunglasses.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
Those are the days where
you're just having a good day.
[LAUGHTER]
I love muumuus.
I have nothing against muumuus.
They're great.
LISA LEE: And so you talked
about your background,
and your culture, and
dance, for instance.
Has that influenced
your focus on comfort?
Because obviously
as a dancer, you
need to be able to
flow with the clothes.
And how has that
influenced your life?
LUBOC AZRIA: Well, I think
as a dancer, one thing that I
learned is discipline.
I think you have to be really
disciplined as a dancer
and you have to be
very consistent.
And the other thing I learned
how a woman's body moves.
So I actually fit every
single garment in BCBG.
There's nothing that leaves,
except for BCBCGeneration,
but BCBGMAXAZRIA, or Herve
Leger, the Runway line,
I actually physically
fit it on our fit model.
And I go over all the details.
And I actually put it
on myself, as well.
Because I want to
know how it feels.
Because I believe that
if you need alterations,
then-- most women think
that there's something
wrong with their bodies.
There's nothing
wrong with your body.
Your body is beautiful.
There's something wrong
with the fit of the clothes.
There's amazing brands out
there that have great quality
and they look good.
But you put it on
and you look dumpy.
And understanding proportions
I think is very important.
Understanding textures,
fabric, colors is important.
So when I'm actually in the
fitting room-- by the way,
my fit model is not
somebody who's very young.
She's actually in her 50s.
And the reason why is you can
take a beautiful, young model
and everything is going
to look good on her.
But you take a
50-year-old model and you
try to make her look amazing,
that's the difference.
And so I actually
do the opposite.
I take something that I
think-- she's beautiful anyway.
But it's just more of
appreciating what happens
and where you need a lift.
LISA LEE: And in terms
of comfort-- I mean,
I think that's one
of the challenges.
Like, I know for myself,
wearing heels, it looks great.
I'd love to wear them every day.
But it just doesn't
seem that comfortable.
LUBOC AZRIA: Right.
LISA LEE: What's your
recommendation for balancing
practicality with style?
LUBOC AZRIA: I think
it's the same thing.
I think have a pair of shoes
with the heels in your bag.
I mean, right now bags
looks suitcases anyway.
I just think it's important--
like if you're in a meeting,
it's nice to wear a heel.
You're sitting down anyway.
If you're running
around, obviously it's
better to wear something
that's comfortable.
I mean I run a marathon.
So my feet grow a half
a size every time I run.
It's getting ridiculous.
Anyway, I like comfortable.
I always have either flip-flops
or something in my bag,
just so that I can relieve pain.
But I have to tell you,
technology, let's talk it.
You guys are in the head
of technology, right?
Why can't we get little
massage pads inside the shoes
so you can just plug-in?
So when you're
sitting there, you're
actually getting a massage.
[LAUGHTER]
I want to buy remote
control luggage.
Can we talk about
when you're traveling?
There's remote control cars.
Why isn't there a
luggage remote control?
LISA LEE: [INAUDIBLE].
LUBOC AZRIA: Yeah.
You just go, right?
I'm serious.
There's so much to invent.
I was sitting and
having a conversation
with someone yesterday.
And they were talking about
all this technology for clothes
and your clothes can
light up in the dark.
And I thought, well, OK.
If you have a purpose for
that, I think it's important.
But there's so much innovation
in textiles right now.
There's fabrics that
make you feel good.
They have a little bit of
copper in it and something else.
I mean there's so
much innovation.
It's very exciting.
Because the clothes are supposed
to protect you, and make
you feel beautiful, and
make you feel comfortable.
But not everywhere do you
want to be comfortable.
Remember, the
moment you're really
comfortable that means
that you're not living,
you're existing.
Like, it's nice to be a little
bit uncomfortable in everything
because that's how
you're moving forward.
Think about it.
If you're too
comfortable, you're
not probably producing what
you could be producing.
If you have a little
discomfort-- like,
I'm always looking
at the collection.
And if it's too
perfect, I'm like, no.
Something is really
wrong with that.
LISA LEE: It's motto we
live by here at Google.
Always try things that are-- or
always uncomfortably excited.
LUBOC AZRIA: Absolutely.
I think that's how you live,
and you grow, and you evolve.
Complacency doesn't
get you anywhere.
LISA LEE: Right.
So talking about technology,
I'd love to ask you,
do you have a favorite
Google product?
LUBOC AZRIA: Yes.
Google Image Search,
can't live without it.
Yes.
Absolutely.
LISA LEE: And how do you use it
and how does it influence you?
LUBOC AZRIA: Every day, I
just literally with research
for images.
I remember we used
to go to libraries
and sign the books out, and
bring them, and then copy them,
and then put them in folders.
I mean I don't
throw away anything.
It's a really bad idea.
And so now, it's amazing.
You can just really find
anything, save it, use it,
print it out.
I mean we will make the most
amazing inspiration boards.
It's fantastic.
LISA LEE: Yeah.
And what about in
terms of social media?
I mean I think there's
Twitter, there's Instagram,
there's Google Social.
How do you use that to
connect with your customers
and to get to know them better?
LUBOC AZRIA: Well, I remember
when we did our first runway
show in 1996, in New York,
people didn't know who we were.
And we were the first
contemporary company
to show during the Fashion Week
in New York with designers.
And I don't know if you
know the whole idea?
Design is really a price point.
That's all it is.
Everything is designed.
There's no product
that's made generically.
Even a t-shirt, I think
t-shirts are the hardest things
to fit anyway because you
need to get that fit right.
Anyway, going back to--
so whoever reviewed us,
defined us.
And they put us
into a certain box.
And there's nothing
we can do about it.
Because at that time,
there was no social media
to tell you a story,
to tell your message,
to inspire, to
connect, to really
make the consumer
or your audience
understand you as a
company, your DNA.
So I feel that social media
now, it is incredible.
We tell our stories.
We tell our passions.
We connect.
Whether it's Twitter, or
Pinterest, or Instagram,
whatever it is, we're
telling stories.
And they're curated because
it's our point of view.
That's how we would
want to see things done.
And I think you
see the aesthetics.
You see our sensibility.
You see your passion.
You see our creativity.
You see who we connect to.
And that's unique to each brand.
And I love that
everybody's on social.
I really do.
And I love the Twitter.
I love that you
can send messages
to the world about what
you're doing and connect.
LISA LEE: That's great.
And so how does that influence--
in terms of, like, design,
like do you ever think
about, oh, someone's
given me this great idea.
LUBOC AZRIA: Absolutely.
LISA LEE: And we need to move
sort of a different direction
that what we were
originally thinking.
Does that happen?
LUBOC AZRIA: Yeah.
So what usually happens is
that we get a suggestion
and we meet people.
I'm very big about meeting
people and understanding
their needs.
Because obviously, we
don't create everything
for ourselves.
But there is a definite need.
So through social media
we have, we love our fans.
Or we have a Week
of Chic or things
that we do to really get
closer and understand
what our fans like.
And so I think in terms
of ideas, I don't know.
We're so creative, too creative.
We need to be more
operational, people.
LISA LEE: And what are some
of the latest inspirations?
LUBOC AZRIA: I've got so many.
LISA LEE: You know, kind of
come across some of them.
Do you just wake up in the
morning thinking about them
or as you're just walking
down the street you
see things that spike interest?
LUBOC AZRIA: Lisa, I
think it's everything.
I think being here,
you never know.
I might do some primary
colors [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
I think the idea is that
what you connect to.
I think that art
is very important.
Does any of you paint or draw?
Self-expression,
how difficult it
is when you actually step away
from it and put it on a wall.
So I think art to
me is very personal.
And what we connect
to is personal.
So that's a huge influence.
Travel is great.
You know, textiles.
People, I work with
the most creative,
amazing, innovative people.
And I'm obsessed with them.
And most of the time,
they come up with ideas.
And I'm just like,
oh, I'm not so sure.
[LAUGHTER]
And really, I love it.
No, I think it's really
working with the team
and really kind of connecting.
And I think they bring a lot of
ideas and then we share ideas.
My overall job is
not just to design,
it's to really bring clarity.
Because if we throw
everything against the wall
and see what sticks,
it takes too long.
I'm almost like, I
edit a point of view
to make sure that-- it's
one thing being creative.
It's another thing
being successful.
We create for a woman.
And we want her
to feel beautiful.
And obviously, we're not
going to do three sleeves
or we're not going to make
her look like a clown.
And I always want a woman
to look a certain way.
A woman always wants
to look taller,
and slimmer, and more elegant.
LISA LEE: It sounds
like you work
with a lot of
inspirational women.
LUBOC AZRIA: I do.
LISA LEE: And so for yourself,
you've become very successful.
Any advice you'd give to
the women in the audience
about becoming a leader in your
space, and sort of the path
that you took, and
the characteristics I
think that you find most
important in leaders?
LUBOC AZRIA: Absolutely.
I think we need to
define what success is.
Success to me is
doing what you love,
and having passion, and living
your life so that you're
exhaustive about passion.
That to me, is truly success.
In terms of being
a leader, I think
it's surrounding
yourself with people
who are better than you are.
That takes strength
and that takes courage.
People are everything.
We work in a community.
And you really have
to surround yourself
with people who
bring out the best.
And in terms of leadership,
live by example.
If you challenge somebody,
they have to do that, make sure
you can do it as well.
And I think that's important.
People don't work for a company.
People work for other people.
And I think it's important as
a leader to be true to that,
to be honest, to
lead by example,
and collaborate with people,
give people opportunities.
I think that's so important.
And I have just a quote.
I have this amazing quote
for all of you females,
by Madeleine Albright.
Because she said, "Women
who do not help other women
have a special place in hell."
[LAUGHTER]
And the reason why she said that
is because a majority of women,
they are not CEOs, or CFOs
or at the top of the-- I
call it the food chain-- is
because other woman sabotaged
them, not men.
Women sabotage women.
So if we stop doing that, there
will be more leaders out there.
And our goal-- I mean
we have a whole program.
It's called Contributor
Program, that I
think is extremely important.
So it takes women that
perhaps are not in the news,
or women who are just incredible
leaders in their own rights.
I wrote their names.
It was Padma Warrior, who
is with Cisco Systems.
She is beyond amazing.
She was one of our
first contributors.
And I loved her strength,
her passion, her vision,
and how she made it
to the top with just
caring about other people.
She never thought about herself.
Do you know what I'm saying,
always doing by example.
I have another female, Claire
Rothman, who is amazing.
She is 86 years old.
She was the head of
Forum, an amazing woman,
and how they did it.
And they did it through
recognizing other women,
never stabbing anybody in
the back, caring for people,
understanding,
following through.
And I think that's
true leadership.
And so on in this Contributor
Program that we're doing,
there's videos
that you can watch.
But they're just amazing
women, who just simple.
It's not about
being complicated.
LISA LEE: It's about
knowing who you are
and being true to
yourself, it sounds like.
LUBOC AZRIA: Absolutely.
LISA LEE: That's great.
I wanted to make sure we had
time to run the runway show.
LUBOC AZRIA: Yeah.
Yeah.
LISA LEE: And make
sure that you can
get some commentary on that.
LUBOC AZRIA: Great.
LISA LEE: Anything you can
give us in terms of ideas?
What are your favorite
pieces in this runway show?
LUBOC AZRIA: Oh, sure.
OK.
So let me tell you
the inspiration,
so you kind of get an idea.
And then I'll walk
you through it.
So basically the
inspiration started
is, I was in New
York City, where
the runway shows are basically.
So I was at ABC Carpets, which
is one of my favorite stores.
If you're ever in New
York, you have to visit.
But it's basically furniture,
carpets, accessory, everything.
And it's curated in
such a beautiful way.
I was so inspired.
And so I went to
the fifth floor.
And there's amazing rugs.
They're either rugs done from
Eastern Europe, Persia, Turkey,
all over the world basically.
And what they do is
they take-- and they're
the most gorgeous
colors you've ever seen.
And they look familiar.
They look like the
are traditional rugs.
But they're are not.
And I was so impressed
with the process.
So I googled it.
And it's called Color Reform.
And what they do is they take
carpets that are damaged.
So carpets that perhaps are
not so great or carpets that
didn't make it to "A grade."
And they bleach them,
dry them in the sun,
and they redye them.
And each carpet
is one of a kind.
And I thought that
was so innovative.
Anything, whether it's
in fashion or in tech,
what makes a company
successful is passion, vision,
and innovation.
And they have done this
with these carpets,
where each artist
puts passion into it.
The innovation is
how they're done it.
It's just such a great process.
So anyway, I was
obsessed with it.
So I took pictures, tons
of pictures of the carpets.
And the prints that
you're going to see here
are actually done
from the carpet kind
of pictures and inspiration.
So we did graphic
design, obviously,
and printed it on silk.
And then the other inspiration
was we're in California.
So it's about sort
of bohemian spirit.
It's about women--
like, I wanted
her to just feel so
beautiful, elegant, and airy.
And I just wanted that
bohemian side to come through.
And then on the third
note, my daughter
just got married,
actually last week.
So it was such a beautiful
event, I have to tell you.
She was she was stunning.
And, yeah, it was
quite emotional.
So when we were working
on this collection,
I kept on thinking
so this is everybody
that's walking down the aisle.
[LAUGHTER]
The whole party,
this is how I want.
That's the finale that
you're going to see.
But that's how I want everybody.
Of course, that's not
what ended up happening.
LISA LEE: I have to
say, how much does she
let you influence her?
LUBOC AZRIA: Remember, in
life, it's not what you want.
It's what you get.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So, very important, when we do
shows, the first five models,
this is their first show ever,
meaning they don't-- I want
to promote young women here.
So this is just
really beautiful.
So we have a little bit
of this kind of strength.
The belt that they're wearing,
which is like a karate belt,
that that with everything
being very feminine,
it's nice to give
it that strength.
In fashion, you need
opposite things.
If something is very fragile,
give it something hard.
That's what makes
it contemporary.
So that's actually--
well, where's the dress?
This is a perfect jumper,
until you turn around.
There you go.
So this is your swimming
jumper actually.
So do you see a little
peek where her shirt is?
That's a little
bit of the carpet,
kind of feel, the design.
They're actually
quite beautiful.
And I love all the
trapunto stitching
which is done on this jacket.
Now, do you know why
models don't smile?
Because you're modeling clothes.
You're like a hanger.
So if they smile,
you smile, then
your attention
goes off somewhere.
And also, they walk
kind of interesting.
They walk like
this a little bit.
And the reason why is sol
the clothes don't wrinkle.
And I love the
idea of versatility
and just having the
vest being versatile.
They're all reversible.
Now, where is she going, guys?
Come on.
I say to Starbucks.
[LAUGHTER]
I dare one of you to wear
this to the corporate meeting.
[LAUGHTER]
In real life, it's
a little higher.
Yeah.
Can you imagine.
I'm sure you'll get attention.
They'll ask you.
But that's what it's
all about, right?
Great clothes open all doors.
I also think that there's
something really beautiful
about surprises.
Like when a woman comes
towards you, you're looking.
Most of us try to-- or men--
try to look at their face.
But when they turn around,
there's always something.
So I believe that
the back sometimes is
more important than the front.
Because as they're walking
away, everybody's looking.
Yeah.
I love these models.
They're so tall and
so uncomfortable
with their bodies.
You should see it.
It's so funny.
There's a little
thing that they do.
So I fix them before
they come out.
So I'm like, you know, like.
And there's so much
static spray in the back.
Oh.
So you're just like
spraying and you're fixing,
and you're making sure.
And they're like
standing there like this.
They're 17 years old, 18, 19.
Half of them don't speak
English, which is fantastic.
[LAUGHTER]
And they're just standing there.
And then once the light
hits them, they're like,
this is done.
It's all done.
It's nothing.
When the light
hits them, they're
like-- it's like you're
seeing them appear.
It's so crazy.
This is gorgeous.
And so this is actually,
again, from the carpets.
They're like, ah.
This woman, her name is Mijo.
And she's amazing.
She's from Macedonia.
Do you guys even know
where that is on the map?
Google it.
But it used to be were
Alexander the Great came.
That country used
to rule the world.
And again, they're
just effortless pieces.
You just put them on and go.
You can put a denim
jacket over it.
You can put heavy boots with it.
It's how you wear it.
I always feel like
you should dance
in the rain in your clothes.
And if you can't dance
in the rain then--
did you ever want to
put a beautiful dress
and just go swimming in it?
Do it.
[LAUGHTER]
And by the way, we have
to-- so the runway shows,
the garments actually are fixed.
But we can't really
have everything open.
Down the runway, you need to get
that wow feeling for editors.
So you don't line the
dresses most of the time.
And you leave things a
little bit more open.
But in real life,
it's much more safe.
Yeah.
She's gorgeous.
LISA LEE: I love how you
carry the theme of the belt
throughout too.
LUBOC AZRIA: Yeah.
LISA LEE: It adds that strength.
LUBOC AZRIA: It's great.
This collection is so
interesting because
from the beginning, from
the first piece to the time
that it actually makes it to the
store, I see it like 30 times.
And I know when
something is good is
when I'm not tired of it.
Like, I'm still excited to
go then and actually wear it.
And that to me is when the
collection really resonates.
And this is all
like handkerchiefs,
all done in chiffon, which
is just cascading down.
And this I just love.
And see how the
girls are tougher?
The more feminine the clothes
are, the tougher for the girls
are.
I like that.
[LAUGHTER]
There's no story behind this.
And see how beautiful she is,
but the clothes is then tied?
Because she's too pretty.
You put her in this sweet
dress and it just doesn't work.
[MUSIC AND SINGING]
This should be
everybody's wedding song.
Um.
So that was going to be
my outfit for the wedding.
But you can't wear white.
[LAUGHTER]
But that's a perfect bride.
Isn't that cool?
Can you imagine somebody?
That's like, yummy.
And, obviously, I love jackets.
So I was saying,
Monica and I today
will look like we're
from the rock band.
And this is so pretty.
That's also like an
amazing wedding dress.
But, of course, my daughter
decided to wear something else.
[LAUGHTER]
And that's all
handkerchiefs, too.
Again, they're not
that low in real life.
And this is my angel dress.
Those are wings.
I thought if you
ever want to fly.
And one of my good friends,
Bo, just wore this to a premier
in New York.
But she's so beautiful.
Again, you don't need
to show that much skin.
It's about sort of
the flow of things.
She's so nervous.
Now, don't forget that this
is the first show in New York
Fashion Week.
But this opens up New
York Fashion Week.
And we had like people weeping.
And it's 10:00 AM.
So people probably didn't have
enough coffee or maybe too
much coffee.
They're going through
some emotional--
so that was going
to be my dress.
And then for the wedding, but it
wasn't about me at the wedding.
[LAUGHTER]
Although, I imagined
that it was going to be.
Again, have fun
with the clothes.
LISA LEE: [INAUDIBLE].
LUBOC AZRIA: Just enjoy it.
It's so much fun.
It's so funny.
We asked the model, so
what do you think when
you're going down the runway?
What are you thinking?
She's like, pizza,
where am I going
to get my nails done, where
do I-- I'm like, really?
Pizza, I know.
[APPLAUSE]
And that's my pookie.
That's by husband.
[END PLAYBACK]
Now, he's my muse.
I know.
LISA LEE: Thank you so much
for the commentary on that.
I mean it definitely, I think,
sheds a different viewpoint.
And just analyzing it, so you're
not just seeing the clothes
and how beautiful they
are, but the contrast.
The belt, the lines, how
they're very simple, but strong.
And yet, you've got the flowy
component of the chiffon.
So congratulations.
LUBOC AZRIA: Thank you.
LISA LEE: I think we're all
excited that it's the weekend
and we can go shopping.
I wanted to make sure we
left some time for questions
from the audience, if
anybody has any for Luboc?
AUDIENCE: Since you
joined the company in 1991
and it have been to 2015 now,
has the vision for the company
kind of changed?
And how are you actually
contributing to driving it?
And what's your corporate
story, a little bit?
LUBOC AZRIA: It has changed.
Well, it hasn't changed.
It has evolved.
I think that in the beginning,
the difference between BCBG
and another company,
it is design-driven.
It's not merchant-driven.
Do you guys know the
difference between it?
So merchant-driven, it is like
a GAP, or Banana Republic,
or companies that sort of
produce based on the new units.
Like, it's a little bit
more-- it's different.
Design, we're design-driven.
So basically we create
things that we want to wear.
So it's very different.
So with the times-- and we've
seen economically what happens.
Do you know what I'm saying?
So you have to always change
and evolve a little bit.
At one point, we
had 20 divisions.
Then we went to,
like, six divisions.
So you're constantly
trying different things.
When we originally
started BCBG-- well,
Max started BCBG,
let me clarify this.
He started BCBG in 1989.
When I joined the company
in 1991, Max at the time
was doing item business.
He was doing pleated
skirts, stirrup pants.
He wasn't doing collections.
When I joined the
company, I realized
that there's a huge void.
At that time, there was
either Donna Karan at the top
or there was Casual Corner.
There was nothing in between.
I mean you had a white
space that was so-- I
didn't understand how you cannot
make clothes in the between
range.
So we were one of the first
contemporary companies,
basically in America, to
create that type of fashion.
With time, more people started
going in that territory.
So you had to kind of
decide which other places.
You're constantly
looking for voids.
And once you realize that a
woman dresses based on her body
shape, not based on
trends, you start
creating clothes
that are versatile,
that are right
for her lifestyle.
So you kind of evolve it.
So I don't believe in
one particular formula.
I believe you are changing,
evolving, and growing.
So with my position
in the company
I think-- when I became
creative director.
Now, I'm more involved
with marketing.
So you have other departments
start reporting to you
because your vision
is so direct.
So one thing in fashion is you
don't want to be anybody else.
Your DNA defines you.
Like, for example, Herve
Leger has a very distinct DNA.
And I'm not going to start
doing something for them
that I think out that alignment.
With BCBG as well, I
will not do-- like, I've
been trying to do jeans though.
But I will always stick to
making a woman feel and look
beautiful.
I will not make clothes
that sort of doesn't
do that and evolve.
But my position the
company has grown
in terms of how many departments
report to me, which makes it
very little time for me.
LISA LEE: More demands.
LUBOC AZRIA: Just a little.
AUDIENCE: My question is more
on the career development side.
So obviously, we
all work in tech.
And it can be more of a
male-dominated industry.
And so I'm wondering
what your experience is
like as a female leader in
such a female-centric industry?
And what that looks like as
you kind of rose in the ranks.
And what that looks like now
as maybe a female community,
where, like you were
saying, you're employing
future female leaders?
LUBOC AZRIA: Well, my
situation is very different.
Don't forget that I
actually married Max.
So I was already on
top of food chain.
[LAUGHTER]
But I have to say that I
really-- I wanted to learn.
The one thing I've
learned is fashion
is still very male dominated.
The bankers, the real estate,
everything, it's very male
dominated.
I think what you need to do is
really be there, be honest, do
more than you need to do.
And I think it's being
present, communicate well.
I mean men are very
simple creatures.
And I'll explain to you
why they are simple.
Because we bring men--
women create men.
And we bring them up.
And all they need
is significance.
You tell them that
they look good,
you tell them that they do well,
that the projects that they did
were great.
You align with them.
And you see the
results happening.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Like I said, you just have to--
they're not your-- you just
communicate well.
And that's it.
You communicate well.
You be open to their ideas.
You show them your ideas.
Before I was at BCBG, I
worked for a designer.
And I remember leaving sketches
every single day on her desk.
She didn't want any help.
But I would leave
it just because I
thought this was a great idea.
This was a great
idea, maybe this.
We like to see passion.
We like to see people
who want to do more.
We like to do that.
And with that, you
can really grow.
Nowadays, I think
everybody is always
looking for that next
talent, that next person
with great ideas, innovation.
And also put yourself
always-- if you think about
me, me, me, me, you're
never going to get there.
Like if I'm creating
clothes to make money,
I will fail every single day.
You have to have
a greater purpose.
So if your purpose is to
get a higher level position,
then you need to read
the job description.
You guys don't have
job descriptions here.
But you have to see what
that person is doing
and what they're excelling at.
Do you know what I'm saying?
And then you see, can
I actually do that?
We talked earlier about success.
And it's very lonely at the top.
And if you're the
type of person that
likes to connect with people,
collaborate, and be together,
and the whole thing,
at the top sometimes,
when you have to
make every decision--
it's not always
right for everyone.
I just want to just
put it out there.
As a woman, we like
to collaborate.
We like to share.
We like to do different things.
At the top, it's
kind of you have to--
Like my husband, a
lot of times, he'll
make decisions that I
totally disagree with.
But I'll sit there and
I'll talk to him about it.
I'll have him explain to me
why he made the decision so I
can better support his vision.
And that's what
makes a difference,
not just saying, OK, I'll do it.
No.
Don't just do it.
You understand the whole--
like the difference
between, I think,
a lot of people
who are at the higher
level, why they
make perhaps a
smarter decision, it's
not because they're smarter.
It's because they
see the whole thing.
So they know that this
person is already doing this,
and this person is already doing
this, and this is doing this.
So you can connect
the dots better.
Where, if you are
only doing that,
you can't see other parts.
So I think in terms of
growing as a leader,
I think you want to
make sure that you're
supporting, learning, growing,
read more, educate yourself.
In nature, anything
that doesn't grow, dies.
Anything that doesn't
contribute, gets eliminated.
LISA LEE: What I want
to hear from that
is you're also leaning
on some of the skills
that women are strong at,
collaboration, listening,
and communication, and
pulling those ideas together.
LUBOC AZRIA: Yeah.
I mean if something goes
wrong, instead of saying, ah,
it went wrong.
You say, what can I do to
make a difference right now?
What can I do to fix this now?
Not just walking away and
saying, well, you know,
it happened.
No.
It's not.
You can make a difference.
I mean at BCBG,
we're always saying,
we're here to make
miracles happen.
We really do.
We make incredible--
and being here
is pretty much a
miracle right now.
[LAUGHTER]
But we do.
We make it happen.
AUDIENCE: So I have a question
in regards to tech wearables.
How do you see that tying into
your design in the future?
And do you see that
as really adding
to women, and your
design, and your vision?
LUBOC AZRIA: Well, I think
you guys are innovators.
So you tell me.
Because I think the tech
wear-- I mean I tried FitBit.
I tried different things.
And I think right now my
comfort zone is not that.
But that's just me.
I'm actually looking to
innovators for ideas,
and collaborating, and
really kind of connecting.
Because I think that
technology is not my strength.
But I'm so curious, so curious.
I want to leave you-- there's a
great story that I want to tell
you, that is really sweet.
Do you guys know a
story about coffee bean?
Not the coffee bean,
like coffee bean.
No.
So when you take
an egg, raw egg,
and you put it in the
boiling water, what happens?
It gets hard, right?
Come on.
I don't cook.
But you guys, you cook.
LISA LEE: We actually
have [INAUDIBLE].
LUBOC AZRIA: So when
you take a raw egg
and you put it in the
boiling water, it gets hard.
When you take a carrot
that's hard on the outside
and you put it in the
boiling water, what happens?
AUDIENCE: It softens up.
LUBOC AZRIA: And when
you take a coffee bean
and you take it and put
it in the boiling water,
what happens?
It transcends.
It creates something that is
beautiful, that's desirable,
that's delicious.
I love coffee.
So in the tough
situations, are you
going to be like an egg, that's
hard on the outside, soft
inside, but gets harder?
Are you going to be like a
carrot, that's really tough
and get all mushy?
Are you going to
be a coffee bean
and transcend, and
find other ways?
And so I think all
of you are pretty
much are coffee beans
because otherwise
you probably wouldn't
be working at Google.
LISA LEE: Thank
you very, very much
for sharing your thoughts, your
spring line, and your thoughts
on leadership.
I really appreciate
having you here.
LUBOC AZRIA: It's
such a pleasure.
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]